we will actually start so welcome
everyone to this meeting of cabinet
uh before we actually get on to the
proceedings
um i'm tony jefferson i'm leader of the
council
cabinet members when invited to address
the meeting please ensure your
microphone is switched on
so it can be picked up via the live
audio
feel feed when you've finished
addressing the meeting
please turn off your microphone
immediately please ensure you have
switched off
or to silent any other devices you have
that may interrupt the proceedings
please note that this meeting is also
being broadcast
live and members of the public not in
attendance today
are able to view the proceedings we now
move to the agenda
apologies for absence and
we have apologies from councillors
fitter and junaid
and councillor pemberton is running a
couple of minutes late
thank you anne uh disclosures of
interest do i have
any disclosures of interest
i'll take that as a no sorry mark
yeah no just an item in there about
temple grafton
um and xor the parish plan i am the ward
member for there
yes uh councillor roth
thank you
councillor shenton and likewise i have
to now declare that my wife has an over
65's
permit
[Laughter]
thank you councillor shenton interesting
right moving on minutes confirm and sign
the minute of the meeting held on the
17th of may
councillor harvey um
thank you leader can i turn to a minute
seven four eight straps upon even town
football club
there's nothing inaccurate about the
minute but i think is
incomplete i think from the officers
point of view it would be
advantageous if the actual amount
that was set out in the paper to be
written off
under that discussion and decision if
that was that figure was to be included
in the minute
i think if they were then any question
from internal or external auditors at
some later stage
there would be absolute clarity about
what the decision was and the extent of
the loan to be written off
mr buckland sherman thank you for that
and councillor harvey had the
um gracer consultants before today's
meeting that for the for the avoidance
of any doubt
the section 151 officer would like it
recorded that the figure of 234 thousand
two hundred and eighty pounds is the
figure that was written off as
part of the cabinet decision last time
and we'll record that in a minute thank
you
thank you mr brooklyn sir with that
amendment to the minutes
uh are the minutes acceptable and could
i have a proposal in the second of for
the minutes please
yes thank you councillor barker and
councillor kettle so
moving on item item four item four
is deferred to a future meeting of
cabinet
uh more work is needed on this item
so moving on uh
item no council of pemberton not being
here
uh i think we should rearrange the
priorities
and take uh item six ahead
of item five item six community safety
priorities
counselor kettle
uh thank you mr uh mr chairman um sorry
i'm just trying to get the
right page of it um
this is a um
an ordinary item as it's not exceptional
it's carried forward thank you um
from um well the pre the previous year
we had priorities this year we're
looking at the priorities
um there's been a significant amount of
research
into what the community safety
partnership priority should be
they are adopted in the february meeting
um and they need to come forward to this
cabinet uh to confirm uh for this
council
that they are happy with the priorities
um
so uh i think the paper is very clear
and i'd like to thank all the staff
involved in putting it together
uh but if there are any questions um i'm
delighted to answer them or if they're a
little more technical nature
um the um team leader is here as well
to help
thank you councillor kettle i do have a
couple of questions unfortunately
uh second item down on the diagram
on page 78 uh
personal robbery in stratford-on-avon
district
on the series acquisitive crime do you
have any elaboration on that point
i haven't got i haven't got um the
detail on it i can come back to you
uh in writing if if that would help
uh unless judy do you have any update on
that
i think uh as i represent stratford
uneven
uh i think it will be very useful just
have a bit of elaboration on that if you
could please
thank you i'll arrange for that happen
okay and i do notice the cross-cutting
theme particularly drugs and alcohol
and certainly the county line activities
and the prevalence of drugs across the
district is a
really serious issue and i'm very
pleased to see that
as a cross-cutting theme and county
lines
as a particular priority i think those
are
really really important councillor
harvey
and then council thank you
um this is not a can i catch you out
question
um item six
two one uh of the paper
uses the phrase secured grant funding
from the
pcc and goes on to mention a figure of
just under 80 000 pounds
um can we do you happen to know this
perhaps very unfair of me do you have
that
off the cuff as a kettle uh
what the total amount of grant funding
that has been secured
or was it limited to that eighty
thousand pound or seventy nine thousand
seven
sixty nine that's mentioned
um this was
this was a specific um
uh grant claim that we went in for
for the installation of cctv cameras
um in in not just in stratfor but across
across various sites within the district
um and
um we are again submitting further under
the straight safer streets partnership
for additional funding going forward um
now most of these i can confirm as well
that most of these sites have the the
cctvs in
uh there are two remaining sites under
this scheme where we're still waiting
for the
final installation to be completed
councillor barker
thank you mine was um on the same one in
terms of
tackling um county lines i
suspect that all councillors sitting
here have had more experience of this
recently perhaps than they ever have
before i've certainly seen it ramp up
where i am
so i want to say to councillor cattle
i'm grateful that one of the cameras
which i don't think is in yet is coming
to shipston
um which will make quite a big
difference but there has been
quite an uptick so i am hopeful
that not only is there an uptick in drug
taking but i'm hopeful that the
policing will be dragged out to the
sticks a little bit more than it is at
the moment and i would
commend councillor kettle's abilities to
try and get that to happen because
we we seem to have got
from my experience more crime occurring
than
we and that i've ever seen before in my
patch
and i suspect that that is true for all
of us yeah you're quite right ships
is one of the two remaining sites uh
waiting to go live
um but um that is on its way
um there are just one or two technical
issues to be sorted out either with uh
bt i think or with with um
the actual installation of the thing to
go up uh
i'm tall enough yeah the the cctv
issue does help hugely i mean as you
know there have been a number of uh
helpful um contributions to crime
reduction in stratford itself relating
to cttv
i'm not going to go into those because
it's likely there will be prosecutions
resulting from it
but i know there have been two instances
where um
one victim was spotted
and and uh paramedics were able to get
to the victim in the back of a car
who was at risk of bleeding out uh from
stab wounds in stratford
uh and have been two cases in stratfor
where perpetrators have been
pictured and those pictures have been
passed on to the police so there's
clearly a huge benefit from cctv
and it will be good uh when the final
two sites are rolled out under the
scheme council harv is referred to
but i think the further the application
making of the
safer streets initiative should include
um i think it's further six sites across
the district
but that is you know that isn't
guaranteed we've got we've got to have
the pcc's approval for that
um and in terms of county lines i think
it is
really really scary um
in two respects one is i had one chair
of parish council who said to me
it doesn't happen in rural warwickshire
so we don't have to worry
um and in his neighboring village
um i have had intelligence that there is
a uh
we they've now got their very own dealer
on the playground
um and so you know there's
just in my patch the evidence that is
taking place uh and as we know
it runs all the way through um the
entire
uh you know from theft to fund it
from um uh
slave people being incarcerated to grow
cannabis or whatever else it may be
within our district
um and it is something which um
for those of you who attended the course
that was put on about 18 months ago
it is a very very scary prospect so i
mean do encourage
all your parishes and your town councils
that if they have the slightest about
say whiff but that's probably the wrong
expression
uh slightest um concern about any
activity in their communities
that they should report it um if it's
in real life in 999 but if not
uh to either the snt's or
if it's in rural areas to the royal
crime teams
because it is um it is something unless
we capture
it and try and control it it will
escalate to levels which are just
unfathomable
thank you for that very thorough
response counselor kettle
and i think you've outlined why county
lines is such a serious and pervasive
issue
with that if i say no further
comments or questions the recommendation
on page 77
that the south warwickshire community
safety partnership priorities for 21
22 they endorsed i assume you are
proposing this
council of kettle i'd like to propose
this mr chairman
councillor pemberton thank you all those
in favor
thank you everyone
we now move back on the agenda
uh to the temple grafton and exo
parish plan june 2021 council of
pemberton
welcome thank you leader and apologies
for uh lateness
even virtual meetings can run on um
members
uh the the item before us here today is
the temple grafton
and ex hall parish plan um parish plans
are a slightly different process to
neighborhood development plans
uh and they are more about the
identification and
of assets and opportunities and needs
for solutions
temple grafton and exel
actually had a parish plan
developed back in 2007 and with
strong foresight and i i recommend their
foresight to
other parish plan and neighborhood
development groups because
um there is an implicit need to review
and update plans
over a period of time even though that's
not specifically
uh indicated through the localism act
but they
they recognize that their plan required
a refresh
and so in 2018 set up a steering group
have underdone a comprehensive uh
round of consultation in exhale and
temple grafton and one of the key key
elements that
uh has come out of that is the
identification of a need for up to seven
new affordable homes uh
uh in and around the uh in in the parish
um so members um uh
the options before us are to adopt
suggest
amendments or not to adopt uh the parish
plan as a material consideration when
determining
planning applications in accordance with
our core strategy
and to regard it as an important source
members my recommendation
is that we adopt the temple graft and an
excellent parish plan
in full thank you are there any
questions
and i see councillor harvey and
councillor kettle
and councillor cargill
p thank you chairman this is a comment
um
can i refer uh members of the cabinet
to page 11 of the supporting document
the parish plan
the figures that took my eye
were stark realism as far as i'm
concerned
when the document quotes 98 of residents
uh own a vehicle and 70 of households
have two or more
um this to me is real life this is what
life is like in
in the in the villages uh three quarters
of the population
of the district live in villages they
don't live in stratford
um and it uh demonstrates
uh the contrast between those who
represent urban awards we're cycling
as a mode of transport for not for
recreational purpose but for
for purpose of actually getting about to
do your shopping or visit the bank or
whatever
is a perfectly good thing to do and a
commendable thing to do
but out in the villages to expect that
that about that amount of uh
of concentration on cycling is is a pipe
dream
these numbers support what we all know
that uh
if you don't sort yourself out for
transport in the rural areas
you suffer and i thought i thought that
was a very
very helpful piece of information from
this particular plan
thank you councillor harvey appoint
well-made councillor kettle
um yes um
a fine document you know no real
questions about
the document no uh comments on that
but it's just an inquiry as to why
they've gone down the
parish plan rather than neighborhood
development plan which would clearly
give them far more
support of the core strategy um because
it would be
underpinned by uh our own core strategy
in the mppf
um i just wondered if you're glad you
can any help on that
the answer is that it's for each
individual
community to decide which of the two
options are most relevant for it
typically neighborhood development plans
are
vehicles for more significant
communities
all the main rural centres the town and
the larger villages
for small much smaller communities such
as temple graph than an exile
the parish plan process adequately meets
their needs
and we have to remember that these are
all put together by
small groups of volunteers and it's a
capacity bandwidth
issue for them and this does what it
says on the tin for them
thank you council of pemberton a very
useful explanation
councillor cargill
i didn't know whether council shenton
was had to meet you
okay fine thanks thank you very much
indeed well obviously i'm i'm very
supportive of the plan
and i think it's a very well executed
plan
as has been mentioned but picking up
council harvest point
in my comments i mentioned about the
fact that
although a beautiful part of the country
i'm so
i'm so pleased to have this particular
part in my patch
it does suffer from connectivity issues
which i mentioned blacks of transport
etc
it does suffer from speeding through the
villages
and the stuff right and uh and also we
don't have a cohesiveness
necessarily there the village hall there
is in dire
need of repair and replacement and i've
been working with
the the parish on this one and i hope we
can perhaps
accommodate a change there with the
county council
as well because that's obviously
fundamental as they are a
land owner there but otherwise uh i
would like to second this report
and say welcome to the to the parish for
doing it
i'm just checking councillor shenton no
thank you
in that case council of pemberton
thank you leader i would just merely
observe for
uh councillors harvey and cargill that
uh you both
bring to the fore the complexity of the
challenges that
face us and um we do need to provide we
do need to come up with solutions to
our transport needs as we move forward
and those will not be
all off-the-shelf cycling and i frankly
doubt even in the town
cycling per se uh will be the would
be the solution given the dem demography
so things like electric cycles electric
trikes may well be a much
bigger component and certainly in a
rural environment we need to be smarter
about
how we ensure that people can move
around as efficiently as possible
and to do so in a way that achieves our
other objectives around
climate change and congestion issues
it's not easy
and it will be something that challenges
us for a number of years yet i imagine
thank you councillor pemberton it's not
easy could turn out to be a monumental
understatement having had a proposal and
a second uh
uh can i have your agreement to the
recommendation on page 43 members of
cabinet
thank you
moving on the next item on the agenda
i believe is councillor cargill uh
council plan monitoring year end 2021
sorry year end 2021
performance report councillor cargo
thank you chad
the this is obviously a historic report
it's it's it's
working um through the last year uh it's
identifying the
the kpis this this council has actually
agreed for itself
obviously the last year has skewed the
figures completely
and from that i have to make the ask the
question
do we now need to have a review of the
kpis mid-term
it's something that i will suggest that
we talk about
also the format of the report and the
other thing i i noticed the chair of rc
is here
i've also asked for a little bit more
clarification of some of the
uh the the figures and such like inside
here
in anticipation so otherwise chair i'd
just like to
recommend the report to to cabinet
i feel i feel personally that we do need
to review this
especially considering we are having now
a merger with warrick district council
and is this report able to
to help us in that particular journey
it's a it's a debating question but uh
something i think we should really
open the opened it up to thank you
councillor cargill
uh councillor parry thank you
thank you chairman i just wanted to
highlight a particular
point on the land charges section which
i note the kpi
is being positioned at three percent of
reaching target and i just wanted to
explain to cabinet
and anybody else listening there are
some very valid reasons for this
particular figure
a during the pandemic the services of
the land charges team had to be
suspended for a couple of months
you will all have been aware what with
the
two stamp duty holidays first introduced
by the chancellor in the first wave
and then extended into june the actual
property market
has ex has has just literally gone off
the scale
it's terribly buoyant it still is
terribly buoyant
as a result of that the land charges
team received
more than double the re the number of
search requests
so to be able to turn that that round in
addition in parallel
they were also preparing uh digitizing
and cleansing around 95 000
different land search records so that we
were
preparing to go live with her majesty's
land registry which actually happened
last month on may the 10th very very
successfully
i would also like to highlight that the
team was restructured back in september
doubled the resources during the last 12
months through the pandemic
there has been no purchaser that has
lost a sale
through the slight delays or you know we
we had a um
an urgency emergency plan in place
just to make sure that we picked up
anybody who was trying to buy a house
so that was in place
and i'm delighted to report with the new
team
under the new regime from hmlr
searches are being delivered with just
under 11 working days so that is a
fantastic
turnaround and i'm sure you'd like to
join me in congratulating
the land charges team for a phenomenal
achievement but it doesn't reflect that
in these
kpis and i just because it's it's the
one that sort of shines out like a
beacon
i did just want to highlight that
there's been a phenomenal turnaround
my thanks also to the head of service
and the whole team thank you chair thank
you councillor parry
i think that was exceedingly valuable
context
i think when you outline the challenges
faced by the land challenges team
and you've outlined the progress made
and the turnaround
i think they really do deserve
congratulations for the way they're
performing now
councillor harvey i believe you wanted
to come in
yes thank you chairman um can i welcome
councillor cargill's intention to um
take the butcher's knife to this lot
and have a go and carve it up in a
different way can it make two
suggestions or two areas where he might
like to give some thought
um page 99 gives information about bed
and breakfast
uh used bed and breakfast and it simply
says that we've gone from using
no units to using 38 units
i would find it a helpful and
informative piece of information
if we could have some sort of an
analysis of
the duration it's one thing for one
family
to occupy a unit for 38 days i know
that's not what this information
says it's another for 38 families to
occupy
a unit for one day each and i would like
to have some sort of
feel for the the duration
of which we have to use bed and
breakfast because we all accept we don't
want to see
anybody in bed and breakfast if it's
avoidable and the second
is on page 103 um
in relation to the last two indicators
percentage of
nnd are collected and and council tax
collected
i would find it far more um informative
if the actual amounts of money
were quoted rather than just the
percentage percentage
i'd like to know how much is at stake
thank you both
the suggestions intended to be helpful
thank you very much councillor cargill
thank you very much yeah i i i get that
now i
i have actually made notes on those two
items plus
others as well and i will be having a
meeting with the team on this
and we'll take it through the uh with
the chief executive
as well because it's his remit i i did
forget one thing i apologize
but i was going to mention that there is
and i think that perhaps julie might be
able to help ourselves on this one
on the percentage of household waste
sent to us reuse recycling and compost
centers
there's some query over the actual
percentage figure on that one
i think councillor shenton might like to
come in on this point
i noticed that councillor shenton was
waiting to come in
however mr brookland i think you may
have had a point on the uh actual cash
collected
yeah i'm i'm happy to prevent provide
both fair because just pounds and pence
might not actually tell you
how good the performance has been in the
last year but if we could give you the
percentage and the value
thank you yes
[Laughter]
yes you can see me hopping and popping a
little bit there yes
you're right we we look at page 101
it has a percentage there of 53.9
um in actual fact julie and i had a look
at this it's 59.4
as a provisional figure for 2021
um not 53.9 as it says in here so
yeah that's me done thank you councillor
uh councillor kettle and then councillor
pemberton
um within your portfolio council cargill
on page 88 um as you know we've been
tracking the performance
of the rollout by bduk broadband in
rural areas
um and the gigabit scheme great
but once upon a time we used to be told
by csw
what their target non-fulfillment would
be
which i think at one stage was the
precise figure of about 3204
properties in stratford district um
i think we're really helpful in these in
in the kpis
some percentage in the future if we
could actually have a far closer focus
on how effective
the rollout is going is taking place
because we now hear 5g
being rolled out in suburban areas
and i know it's a discussion we've had
before but i think it is really
important to understand
if if the suburban and urban areas are
getting 5g
but some of the rural areas getting 2g
what number in the district are
suffering 2g
because i think that's that's quite a
key criteria about the help
sort of rural communication network uh
with that number it's still at three
thousand but it's gone up to eight
thousand when it's gone down to
three hundred i don't know and that's
point one
point two is um on page
and this is just a matter of
clarification
percentage homelessness prevented or
relieved
it's 50 and we achieved 70
of what um i think it'd be helpful if we
could have a
real number in that you know what is
what is the level
because you know 50 of 10 000 people
would be a huge problem
um but perhaps paul pogba holder might
be able to
councillor barca do you wish to
interject at this point i'm not going to
give you the numbers because i never
remember them
but what i would say is that the
difference this year
has been skewed by what the government
has asked us to do
but more than that um it because of the
supply problems or the pipeline of
supply
of housing again because of coved
we've ended up with more people so
than we would have expected because it's
taken longer to move people on that's
now
changed but the the figures this year
won't look
very good but the percentages actually
look very good
council cargill do you want to respond
to any of those issues i thought
obviously council marcus responded i
think quite rightly to the
the homelessness and prevented i will
say that when they say
all relieved i did have to double take
and think what does that really mean
so i'm gonna i'm going to actually ask
for this perhaps
i'm going to use the word plain english
can i pick up councillor kettle's point
though because
as he as he knows that i've been working
hard with
mr platts on this and it has been
detergent journey i think is the
expression
not that long ago we were looking at 4
000 properties within stratford district
which probably only accounted for a
couple of three percent but they were
the toughest
three percent one thousand those homes
are
down to being actually sorted through
normal processes in other words
uh bduk for example open reach are quite
happy they'll be they'll be
into the system and any new development
should be also
it still leaves us with approximately 3
000 properties that are very difficult
to do
right but just a little bit of
background not that long ago our
government
well the prime minister actually said
we're going to roll out full fiber
to the entire country and it's going to
be the outside in not the inside out
well when we had our discussions not
that long ago with bduk they said well
it's
not quite outside it's almost like in
between
in so in other words they renamed on
that already because of whatever they
say
very frustrating for me in
my role on that and also for our
communities who are really really
striking
we do have interim measures uh and i've
i believe now that
certain members have got the kit which
is theoretically able to get
a better signal to some of the more
remote areas i've got one literally
three miles from my
my home on the top of a hill you'd think
they get good signal and it's rubbish
uh anyway to answer your question we've
probably still got three thousand homes
and we're probably looking at around
three or four percent perhaps that are
connected yet
and that has not moved and we are still
working with
dcms to try and improve that it's been a
long
journey thank you councillor cargill i
think you've neatly encapsulated the
frustrations in this
council of kettle do you wish to come
back before i bring councillor pemberton
in well it was just one final point and
that was to say um
how are you expecting cabinet members to
feed in
uh to the kpi reports as to where we
think changes might help
or is that are you going to carry out
the review and
i think in fairness that's for the
officers to to look at that one
we'll look that one but it's a good it's
a valid point and let's
look at how we can actually represent
them better in the next year's
figures thank you for that council of
pemberton sorry
thank you uh thank you leader i think
the the first observation i would make
um across councillor kettles shenson and
harvey's
uh interventions accountants of the
world unite god help us all
i think that we have to recognize that
this
particular report has
improved and become clearer
significantly
over a period of time so i think we
should um
whilst we rightfully challenge and
expect
ever greater performance i think we have
to acknowledge that the officers
and the portfolio holder have worked
hard to
bring to this cabinet a much
clearer set of reporting i think we also
as a cabinet need to remember that
actually this is about performance and
then that should drive
other inquiry and activity and i think
uh the point that
cancer kettle makes is a valuable one um
either in this arena or in overview and
scrutiny it's
entirely unfair to ask the portfolio
holder
to come comment on anything other than
his or her should it be or her in your
role at some point in the future
cancer cargill um on anything other than
their own roommate and i think probably
one of the
learning points moving ahead is that
not just around areas where for example
we're not meeting target because
there are there are there are situations
where you may well be meeting target but
are you it's in the right target is it
is it telling you what you want to need
we'll i think we need to think about a
a more sophisticated process where
perhaps in conjunction with officers and
the relevant portfolio holders who are
impacted by the detail of this that is a
supplementary piece of work or or a
parallel piece of work
to be able to give cabinet and the wider
council
clarity around the issues that underpin
this rather than
as trying to unpick it all within this
particular report so i think
probably my observation is that there's
a there is another piece of work to be
done
or to be evolved in the future so for
example if we're looking at homelessness
prevention
you know we'll you know we we we get to
understand that uh sort of by
on a by exception basis and i think
that's probably something that will then
aid the the usefulness of this
performance reporting because it will
then lead us to
the detail where or the issues where we
need to get into more detail
led by the relevant heads of service and
portfolio holder
thank you councillor pemberton you make
some interesting points councillor
harvey
thank you chairman i'm grateful for the
promotion
but the second thing i'd say is um it
depends
who you think the audience for this
performance review is
and my view is that
the management team are responsible for
the operations
of the council and it is perfectly open
to them and they should
have their own set of criteria by which
they judge their own performance
it strikes me that the cabinet acting on
behalf of the council
has a responsibility to ensure that
policy that's initiated
by the council is is reported upon
and the two reports may be very
different
and it simply may be that as far as the
council is concerned
as far as the management team is
concerned all we need to know is
are they doing their job how do we know
that that's the case but what we're
interested in as a council
is information on the performance in
policy areas
are policy targets being achieved so i
i know that's a fundamental challenge so
to speak but
but it's intended constructively for
those
to those who want to to think about
thank you councillor harvey some
interesting points
uh i think uh councillor cargill
you have a very difficult job in
presenting the council plan
monitoring what i think has been
interesting this afternoon
is that a number of portfolio holders
have
chipped in with supporting information i
think this is an area where there's
always going to be continuous
improvement and i think debating
it means actually we are doing our job
so i would assume counselor cargill you
are proposing the recommendations on
page 81
that is correct second to please
counselor pemberton
all those in favor
thank you members of cabinet so now we
move on
to what i'm sure will be an extremely
brief agenda item
uh agenda item eight parking
consultation results councillor shenton
that wasn't an attempt to lead me in was
it
so the recommendation this
recommendation deals with six particular
areas that's detailed in section
2.2 and section 3 on page one one two of
your packs
four of these deal with parking issues
in car parks whilst the fifth one
is section two deals with motor homes
section three covers the concessionary
permit and i'm sure we'll hear
more on that shortly i don't
at this point intend to go through this
paper with a fine tooth comb as we've
laid out the facts
and included the consultation findings
in the packs for completeness
for the record i'm recommending that all
of the changes
outline in section four should now be
agreed however in addition to the
recommendation on page 111
i'd like to add a second recommendation
and i have run this past
both phil grafton and ross chambers
and the second recommendation
is that the decision on whether or not
to proceed with the revised
off-street parking order in a modified
or
unmodified form following the outcome
of statutory consultation be delegated
to the head of service in consultation
with the portfolio holder i can repeat
that if you need to
other than that
i don't intend to say any more at this
point
thank you thank you councillor shentern
uh
any items from members of cabinet
no councillor ralph you look as though
you wish to speak
thank you chair uh well it's not
surprising i want to speak about the
over 65
parking permit um and
uh firstly first of all i want to say
that the survey is flawed
um it only gave two options which was
150 pounds or not have a permit and most
people got
very very very uh upset about having to
choose between the two
so it was a kind of assumed that
everybody was happy for not having a
permit at all
um no one was in favour of an increase
of 150 pounds
there's no evidence of fraudulent use
i've seen a copy of an email from an
officer stating that the car parking
officers have said they see some people
who don't look
65 this isn't evidence it's anecdotal
because this is taxpayers money we're
using the survey should have been
distributed to everyone
in the district not just the 2000 permit
users this would have given a fairer
response
the argument about carbon neutral is
also flawed
because using the bus service as an
alternative is just simply
not viable i was interested in item five
about the villages
uh there are no buses um from our rural
villages
um so people cannot get on a bus
and even if they could it's unlikely
they'll get back even where i live
um there's two buses a day with a four
hour
um with a four hour gap
so actually what you're doing is
increasing carbon emissions by forcing
people to drive further they'll go out
of town
and they'll even drive around and park
in the residential areas
so it's absolutely clear from the
response to the survey
that no one was in favor of an increase
of 150 pounds
however many residents offered solutions
and it clearly appears that the
following three main points have been
raised
raise the age to over 70 increase the
cost to 25 pounds
and shorten the hours of use to 4 hours
a day
i mean i really want you to take this
seriously this is not
me being opposition this is me actually
being um you know i've had so many
emails and
telephone calls from my residents and in
particular
south of the river you know ships and
wells born there's a lot of
and all the villages in between there's
a lot of people
that use this pass it'll allow people
to use the recreational facilities
shopping entertainment etc
and it will hugely help those volunteers
that help in our charity shops
2 000 permits at 25 pounds a permit
will raise 50 000 pounds which more than
covers
implementing um the car parking permit
residents have stated that if a
permanent is abolished then they'll use
elsewhere to shop hairdressers doctors
dentists banks
and they'll use out-of-town shopping
centers
mostly the older generation use banks
and if banks aren't used we could see
another nail in the coffin with banks
closing
because of under usage older residents
we'll stop using the cafes um it will
stop older residents using the cafes and
restaurants in our town
i mean if you go around town during the
day today for instance you'll see most
people that are using the restaurants
and cafes that are of an older
generation um if you stop this
you're likely to increase tourism i
don't have a problem with that
but we don't want to become a tourist
town
i just want to highlight a couple of
things um
two that really stood out for me
um i know the owner of a local charity
shop
and she said if this if this happens she
will lose
four of sorry three of her regular
volunteers because they cannot afford
to pay the parking fees they're on state
pensions they come and help out in the
charity shops
and i had another residence say ran me
to say that
him and his wife use the bowls club two
or three times a week
and once a week they after playing bowls
they go in
and enjoy themselves in a in a
restaurant um
they won't be able to do it it'll be
prohibitive for them
i i don't want to bring out politics but
councillor o'donnell is sitting next
door but one to me
she has gone in the press almost
agreeing with what i've been saying
um you know it is unfair it is unjust
um i really would like this to go to
full council
to be discussed because i think there
are more councillors
certainly in the south and the west of
our town
that have been contacted by residents
who are really going to struggle
if this is removed and i just want to
reiterate if you made it to over 70
you increase the cost of 25 pounds and
you short me hours of use
it'll hugely help the footfall in our
town and the use of facilities in our
town
and it will certainly help the
volunteers thank you very much
and i'm sorry i didn't mean to bring up
council o'donnell but counselor donald
did
she was chair of ovie and scrutiny and
she did you know
understand what i was trying to say
thank you thank you councillor rolfe
councillor donal thank you chair and uh
it's lovely to see you back
council jefferson and apologies for
being late you're quite right council
pemberton
um online meetings also run over
because we forget about the bit in
between getting over here um
so yes councillor off and i want to
clarify something i think when you said
not a tourist town you meant
not a tourist town at the cost to our
residents yeah rather than not yeah
um and with regards to what was in the
press that was of course
because of the lack of space not the
entire response i gave where i framed it
by saying
i can we have scrutiny discuss this in
great detail and we understand
the need to increase income we
understand that
we were simply asking and councillor um
shenter will not have been surprised
that i raised concerns about it because
councillor shelton has been very
understanding
in our meetings in group and i've raised
the point that the rural communities
are concerned about this because i don't
represent one village that has a regular
bus service throughout the day they're
often two buses a day and that's it
so that was one concern what we were
asking for was the consultation goes
back and it's more nuanced
so it's not um abolish or it's 150
pounds and the two areas are decided in
the report i question if they have the
same
demographic that stratfor has for the
age group because they do have a
slightly older population in stratford
so at osc it was discussed in great
detail
the concern around the volunteers not
being able to afford to come in
and fulfill their volunteering duty was
raised it was also raised that we were
not disagreeing with the fact that the
um permit would have to be increased in
cost it was simply asking
for more options regarding the costs and
julie and craig made the very valid
point that
you know whatever cost you offer people
are not going to necessarily want an
increase but we were framing it at osc
with we understand there needs to be an
increase
but please don't abolish it because by
doing that you are going to increase war
on isolation
and the communities that have been
shielding for 18 months who may not be
able to afford to come in on a state
pension on the
on the regular basis that we're
encouraging them to do so we put off
coming back into what is a very
caring community within stratfor so it's
really asking us to look at a compassion
compassionate narrative around this and
to go back and perhaps look at the
consultation again just on that more
granular aspect for the over 65s
but we're framing it on the
understanding that we realize we need to
increase income but it just seemed far
too black and white
and that's what was coming across at osc
thank you council o'donnell councillor
shenton do you wish to respond
yes please leader um just on a couple of
points
um councillor rolfe
said that uh if we look around the town
during the day
we will see that most people in the town
at the moment are over 65s or elderly
but that doesn't mean that those people
are here
on permits their visitors they could be
from well outside of the area
so the permits and the fact that there
are a lot of people in the town
are not necessarily related at all you
can't link the two
um councillor o'donnell mentions about
the
obviously the rule aspect and we've
spoken about this a number of times
but if we look at the if we do look at
the the survey
um over a third of the people in the
survey
are saying that they they have
disabilities
in which case they may be entitled
to a blue badge sk to add free parking
now that's around 500
if it's a third of the the uh the number
of permits
uh 52 percent of the people in the in
the scheme said they were happy
they would not be happy to pay more
so taking up face value that's 750
permits
and maybe up to 20 of the permit holders
live within two to three miles of the
town center
so what we're seeing is that even quite
easily
um the number of people taking this
permit
will continue to fall it's fallen by 40
percent
over the last two years from 2006 or
2700
down to 1500 currently it is falling
this who we have within the uh the
region
within the district um
we have 127 000 other people that don't
take this permit or are not entitled to
this permit
of those 33 000 of them
are 65 and over
and they don't take this permit
there is no reason to think
that they will take it so 99
of the residents are not not either not
entitled to it
or don't take it and i'm thinking of the
majority here
and therefore i i i listened to the
the the osc debate obviously
um and nothing
new has come forward i i'm still of the
opinion
that we should go forward with the two
recommendations
and i would propose that we move to a
vote
at this point
yeah uh counselor ralph and councilor
donald you wish to speak
i'd be very grateful if you could be
brief please
uh yes it will be we also discussed at
ors about
disability and blue badge holders it's
very very difficult
to get a blue badge believe me you have
to go for a lot of assessments
it's not that easy 52
um said they wouldn't pay 150.
that's because the survey was flawed
if you actually as councillor o'donnell
said if you actually
break that survey down you'll get a much
more realistic
reply they didn't want to pay 150
so you've assumed that they would rather
not have
um a pass i think a lot of them
put forward alternative suggestions and
i've read the result of the
survey very carefully and i've also had
many many many people
contact me and and the response that
the response i gave you about the three
ideas
raising it to over 70 increasing the
cost of 25
and shortening the hours of use to four
hours a day you
this council will still increase revenue
um because the rest of the hours you'll
be getting money on the car park
you'll be you'll be then allowing that
older generation to be able to help in
our charity shops
and take part in activities in the town
um and i do agree with council o'donnell
i mean that that
the survey was flawed and it needs to be
more specific
and there needs to be more alternatives
given thank you
thank you uh councillor ralph councillor
o'donnell
thank you and just clarification i says
for the serve for the
consultation it's repeated to be more
nuanced um
really with regards to the blue badges
it's very difficult to get a blue badge
and also we have that group of people
who are
just about managing with independence
and we have a window with them to keep
them mobile to keep them independent and
after the shielding to to
support their mental health now simply
because
99 don't take the permit up i question
how many are actually aware of it before
the consultation with just the permit
holders and
secondly just because it's not taken up
by the majority doesn't mean it's not
right for the people that were using it
and if they were then to pay the
increase that could come out of a more
granular
consultation then you're not penalizing
them simply because they won't take on
the huge increase that was put forward
so i just think it would give a more
compassionate narrative as to how we're
looking after people as they come out of
the
um you know these unusual times we've
had and i do think from the figures that
counselor rolf comes up with there is
scope for that
i don't see i just don't see the logic
in not going back and having a more
granular approach to be perfectly frank
councillor barker did you want to come
in yes i just wanted to make a comment
on blue badges
um my own experience of applying for
blue badges and i have helped
quite a lot of my residents do it is you
have to be thorough
it's a long form and they
usually depending how able or
disabled somebody is they get a visit
from the county council and it is a
relatively painless process if you truly
need a blue badge i truly believe you
get a blue badge in warwickshire
thank you councillor marker uh
councillor shenton you've proposed the
recommendations
are you sorry i was just about to say
council pemberton are you second in the
motion
[Music]
fine go on thank you um
i would just challenge some of the
things that have been said
um i disagree that the consultation
is not focused not nuanced um
it is right that you should consult with
those are most affected
that's 1537 concessionary permit holders
versus a population of 127 000 people
i would also take issue with
the question of how many choices do you
want
this is in the context that across
neighboring authorities there is either
no
over 65s parking concession provided by
the local authority
or the two that do as i recall charged
150 or 175 pounds
and so the logic of picking 150 pounds
was it was the cheapest of
what's being offered elsewhere so there
is a logic to why there was a particular
price chosen
it wasn't a scatter gonna affect it and
it doesn't really
allow for much more nuance than that and
i would also
challenge this notion of fairness
now it is absolutely true to say that
this is if
if you just want to be popular this is
not something you want to do
you know the easy the easy solution for
us
would be to say you know what we'll give
this go guys okay we'll just let it go
but you do have to make tough choices in
a financial sense
but you always have to make tough
choices around fairness and i
fundamentally think this is unfair and
i'll explain why i think it's unfair
it is true to say that there are
pensioners who live on only the state
pension
there are however a significant number
of pensioners
who have very well rounded and
financially robust pension schemes those
who have benefited from
final salary pension schemes and they're
not all in the public sector
and i then have to explain to my
residents who are
working in the town
explain some viruses
and are working in the town we'll have
to pay the full rate
as against somebody who lives on the
titlington road who can legitimately
afford the sorry avail themselves of the
over 65 permit
and i accept everything that councillor
o'donnell says
about us helping people who are
vulnerable and moving out of this
but there is no such thing as a perfect
system unless we decide to go there in
the roots of a means-tested approach
which of itself is so
uns it is an expensive
bureaucracy to address
what may well be an injustice for a
small number of people but i do think
the injustice for
a larger number of people below the age
of 65
who support the economy of this town who
bluntly will spend more
in shops other than the cafes and the
restaurants
is they need to be supported as well so
i'm not i'm i'm for
backing councillor shenton's uh
recommendation we go to councillor
pemberton
can i take it that that was a second in
the recommendation it certainly was
thank you councillor pemberton
uh welcome technicals members of cabinet
uh please can i have your votes on the
recommendation
on page 111 and the additional
recommendation that
uh councillor shenton proposed
thank you members of cabinet
so moving on uh there are no
reports from cabinet committees there
are no on block items
the cabinet work program was published
on friday
and there are paper copies on the table
by the door
and i would actually recommend that
people look very carefully
at the cabinet work program because
there is a lot on it
so part f of the matters start time
and meeting start time and meetings for
21
22. at the moment we start at 3
30. is that acceptable or do people want
to change it
i will take that as an enthusiastic we
stick with 3
30. is that
reasonable in that case
start timer meeting is 3 30 there'll be
no urge in business
i declare the meeting closed at 4 30.